pilot are you yeah how are you doing I'm
really good nice to talk to you well I
really was over overstating it I'm
holding up everyone is healthy so far
and really ready for us to move on to
whatever the next phase of our new world
is going to be absolutely I must
compliment you you have a lovely
background a very you look very composed
very at home village you know this is a
bit like I remember my childhood my
parents would have people over a party
where like they would clean only the
rooms they would see and then everything
else was shoved into homes three by
three space well it's such a pleasure to
get to talk to you about this special
just because it seems like it was a
really wonderful opportunity to get the
game back together exactly and that's
why it was such a joy and you tried this
technology out that I believe were the
first comedy that's gotten to do this
technology and our show was already the
series was already done when we got the
news that we were going to get to get
back together and make this interactive
special and I'd like to think it could
become a habit if enough people watch it
I mean let's do the Christmas special
let's let's go for it in terms of you
know filming it you know I just it seems
like there is a it was a not the
simplest script to be following right it
was very complicated and I really
believe there was only one or two people
on set who knew what was happening
so it was quite confusing for all of us
certainly the timeline was because you
weren't sure when you film different
pathways what had already happened or
not happened and also the page count was
so underestimated you know we it would
say we were gonna film five pages that
day and you were ended up learning about
14 or more because you we had to film
all the different paths you can go down
and they weren't necessarily all in the
packet of pages that would you'd be
prepped for so yeah it was complicated
but I think there was our show is so
perfect for it and our writers are so
perfect for it we there's so much
material that be as hilarious right
right so many jokes that don't make it
on the page or so many jokes that don't
make it to air that this is a chance for
them to write every joke they ever
wanted to write for us film every joke
they ever wanted and hopefully you can
find every jokes that they ever wanted
to write no absolutely I feel like I
played through it three times now and I
feel like I feel like I've seen nearly
everything but definitely not everything
like I feel like there's still a couple
of calves I can go down I watched the
first one of my son because I needed my
son to show me how to make my remote
work I mean you know when the nine year
olds are running the technical world
right now for at least in this house and
see I see the flesh fillet I haven't
found all the things that I would still
like to kind of find that I know we
filmed at some point so that's that's
the joy you can have what a better time
when we're all need to social distance
to stay home you can stay safe and watch
hours upon hours of unbreakable Kimmy
Schmidt no I mean is there is there
something you know you filmed that you
definitely hope people get to get to
experience I mean there's so many
because there was somebody that I didn't
know that of other people's because when
we did the read-through we only did one
path which I guess if we were going to
have a premiere which we were I guess
they would have just aired one path I'm
not really sure how that would have
worked because there are so many ways
you can go down so for me that was great
delight and seeing what everyone else
filmed and got to do there are so many
scenes that I film but I've not been
able to find yet and I know they're in
there because I did you know ADR for
them so I know they're in there I just
haven't been able to find a whole bunch
one of my favorites that took me a few
goes to find was a little fantasy of
chaplains where she's singing in French
yeah and dancing in the 60s and there's
an astronaut rollerskating guru I'm not
even sure why if this is happening but
we filmed it and the man roller skating
is one of our longtime hair people he's
been with us through 30 rock and does
Tina Fey for everything
his name is ghee and he's amazing and
Tina Fey actually did the scratch vocal
for that to show me how to sing it in
French and I personally loved it so much
I was like please just keep you singing
it because first of all it's hilarious
that I'm lip-synching to you but also
I think it's a like a little hidden
treat for people to go find it and she
sounded amazing she said she had she
sounded way better than I ever was
singing in French that's wonderful I had
no idea - it was it was Tina Fey it is
actually a circle so that might be the
one you want to go search out yeah
absolutely I actually know where it is I
know is I think I when I hit on my first
pass I also did not I was not there the
day Jack McBrayer filmed and so when I
watched it for the first time I saw Jack
McBrayer show up at the prison I was
like wait what you know it's a bit like
when you follow people on social media
you're like wait they're in New York and
they can call me like Jack Kennedy once
said I would expel wherever wherever we
were because I love that guy and it was
a joy to see his hilarious little face
show up on our special you know it was
wonderful um speaking of which I you
know lots of people are talking about
doing reunion specials these days as you
get as the 30 rock cast talked about
that at all I would not be in on those
come bursts or like the early
conversations is so no I don't know I
don't believe so but it was very
comforting to see the Park Parks and Rec
one they made they raise so much money
which was so nice I you know of course
it would be a delight to see everybody
again and hilarious but I am not aware
of any of that you'll just get the email
like what are you doing Tuesday and if
that's the surprise that it is it would
be an absolute joy to see everybody I
know this is we're in such a different
world that I and I think the Kimmy's
special will do this too you're sort of
longing to see the old characters that
you knew before we were in this position
and so it's kind of nice to go back and
feel comforted by that I'm also finding
it incredibly comforting to see our
shows that especially the late-night
comedians coming from their homes it
makes us feel like the world can still
move on and still happen while we're in
this little period of time and it's the
same you know seeing you and getting to
do these interviews with you guys it
feels like our world is still still
going and you know we still do what we
do so thank you for that of course the
the touch of normal it means a lot
they're all
really quickly just to wrap up I wanted
to make sure I also asked you got to
work with Daniel Radcliffe and what was
that experience like well you know I was
we first of all it was incredible that
he said yes to come on this special he's
a big get for us to have on the show and
I only ended up doing I think two scenes
with him so and so I got to know him
very little but I just loved him I
thought he was so game he's hilarious
which you know he had a lot of comedic
material of a cat hold and carry and he
did such an amazing job and I just left
left the project and left working with
him like admiring him I I think he's
he's the real deal and I look forward to
seeing her in the LCD he does in his
career absolutely
well thank you so much for your time
today safe safe you too you know
yep and yeah I hope the rest of these go
well thank you so much so nice to talk
with you